lot of people don't know how you and
Steve met we met on set and then where
was your first date Sun Cafe the
waitress came back like 20 times to get
our order cuz we were just talking the
whole time right and when she got up to
go to the bathroom she was wearing these
jeans and her ass was so rad a and then
there's another thing that she talked
about which was her dog olive and Olive
had like a herniated disc or something
and the vet says she needs this back
surgery or I got to put her down and the
biggest partch of sh ever made was to
save her dog wow those two things really
made me think okay this is an
extraordinary woman did you guys make
plans for the the second date I walked
to the car and he gave her a kiss on the
cheek yeah which was so cute still to
this day I love that and my favorite
thing that you said to me I enjoy you
you said that I said I said I enjoy you
it was so sweet yeah and I said I enjoy
you and uh and I love watching you walk
away girl